no fluff has repeatedly tried to whip up
climate hysteria with over-the-top
comparisons and rhetoric take a look
there's a lot of people now that are
blowing back on the review but the
planet has been in peril in the past who
came forward to save Earth from the
scourge of Nazi totalitarian regimes we
came forward the world is going to end
in 12 years if we don't address climate
change and your biggest issue is your
your biggest issue is how are we gonna
pay for it you cannot go too far on an
issue of climate change the future of
the planet is at stake and now Elizabeth
Warren is being criticized for comparing
herself to JFK and using the anniversary
of the moon landing to call the green
apollo program to fight climate change
what do you think about this waters I
mean they just said the Apollo program
was racist and sexist last week so I
don't know if that's an apt comparison
for the Democrats Cory Booker scares me
he looks hysterical fired up I think he
needs a new outfit too he's got the
sweater and the button-down collar every
single where he goes when someone comes
up to me and says give me all your money
or you're gonna die that's a scam artist
to make or a really good robbery here's
the thing one this is where you know I
love you to death but here we go
don't you think the Democrats need to
take a page of the Republicans playbook
because they're fear-mongering is
terrible like when Republicans make it
when the big thing was they push
terrorism they made it feel like it was
there's a terrorist outside your house
we got to do something now who you you
know and Democrats like with this you
tell some money in 12 years something
Bad's gonna happen we might call you
back at 11 years and three months and be
like what's going on like they they try
to scare you into thinking about things
but they don't do a really good job so
that was give like they give you a
solution you got to work on their
fear-mongering I got to take a page to
make us pay attention wow it's gonna
take fear Mari so I think that personal
you got to realize they're having a
Democratic primary
and there's not much debate among
Democrats that climate change is a real
issue and we need to do something about
it so they are in fact speaking to
people who can vote for them and give
them the nomination and I think that
they are speaking by the way to most
Americans at this point they're
definitely not speaking to the
hard-right trumping you know climate
change deniers if you will to Graham
support he says he follows the signs I
think that's who's out there I and I
don't think there's anything radical
it's you say maybe they need to ramp up
their fear mongering but that to me is a
pretty low sight
there's nothing radical about the green
New Deal no there's a hundred trillion
dollars well I believe me they haven't
even put it into legislation I would
have a little bit more interest in that
line of thinking if we're about the
green New Deal but that wasn't that was
a jobs program that was Medicare for all
that was all this stuff and it's so
pretty Sanders saying there there's no
bill that's too big in order for us to
tackle climate change but they were
tackling everything else but climate
change with that is your point yeah but
there's a lot of kitchen sink in there
have a conversation rather than have
zero which is what the Republicans say
it's not a rational conversation that's
the problem
oh it's not irrational to say we need to
do something an emotional conversation
so I just want to address something that
Elizabeth Warren said and Elizabeth
Warren and Cory Booker are trying to
evoke these memories of World War two
and you know some of the incredible
history we have with military and our
space programs but the difference
between the Apollo program and now
Elizabeth Warren is saying we all came
together and we got guys on the moon and
and that was pretty historic 50 years
ago a phenomenal feat that JFK called
out in 1961 said by the end of this
decade we're gonna have a man on the
moon
and that happened but you have to bring
people together in order to do that and
these people cannot exist their
political curves cannot exist unless
there is constant division and that's
Elizabeth Warren that is Bernie Sanders
that is the squad that is even the
president I will give you that there's
no way you're going to get people to
come together when you live for pushing
them apart wait a second what are you
saying how is it pushing your money
you take us home can you get anything
for the moonshine experts on this
because should from them shouldn't war
be comparing herself to anyone like JFK
like she has kind of a bad things don't
play well for her when she compares
herself to us what's working for her
though it's washing her dog with the
hose that really caught fire on the
internet over the weekend they're lying
to the American people if they want to
fight climate change then we're all
going to pay six to ten dollars per
gallon for gasoline period we're not
going to be able to drive the car of our
choosing we're gonna have to drive some
vehicle that actually might produce more
co2 emissions in making it because of
the battery and because of the cold that
requires to produce the electricity used
to charge our car it will hurt the
poorest of the poor it will hurt the
working man and the working woman who
has to drive two hours round-trip to get
through their job stop lying to the
American people if you want to fight
climate change and change the cars that
we drive and change how we create
electricity we're also gonna put
millions of people out of work
how'd that work out for Hillary Clinton
with the speakers of the coal miners
we're gonna put the coal miners out of
work yeah that really really fool don't
you dare try pretty strong but I thought
it needed an antidote if you know what I
mean that you can do that during the
commercial break all right